thanks for the invitation and the
opportunity to
speak um I was going to tell you a bit
about antoan paral and Alexander Gren
but uh I don't want to be caught by by
the clock so we'll just begin to
interesting
personalities so our our theme is idian
spaces and actually representations of
ukian spaces so we take take a standard
ukian space I index the coordinates by a
the usual indexing is of course the
natural numbers but I'd like the freedom
to be able to change the indexing as we
move along so let me use a a sort of a
an a that will change from Context to
context so we have ukian space with a
DOT product ukian
norm and the closed unit
ball so the question sort of an ancient
well relatively ancient question is how
can we effectively represent ukan
spaces so the generic presentation of L
L2 is via measure spaces so you take a
sufficiently large measurable
space and you consider the L2 space on
that measurable space all square
integrable functions on Omega with a
standard inner product and then you
select an orthonormal family of
functions
and the cardinality of that family
matches the cardinality of the bases of
your ukian space and you define a
map from Little L2 into big L2 which
simply matches the basis right so the
standard basic element in the L 2 will
go to the corresponding element indexed
by it in the orthonormal family so there
is
ux and we have paral
formula par ofal formula simply states
that the dotproduct of X and Y is the
integral of ux u y bar integrated
against the probability measure or the
measure mu that you
have so essentially this formula was
proved by well by by paral but to his
credit he didn't publish a proof because
he said it's self-evident and it is it
is so in the business we say that U is a
unitary map it it's one one it's an
injection and it preserves angles I'm
sorry no it's paral Anan paral 1750
something to 1830
something blel is another story I mean
when you take when you take xal y you
get
plel so plancherel's theorem is the L
little L2 Norm of X is the big L2 Norm
of ux that's plch around but this is par
but let's not you know this is history
it's
not well anyway so U is
unitary and you notice that U is
automatically continuous right because
the well U is bounded the norm of ux is
the Norm of
X so the question now is well okay so
you presented your ukan space via L2
functions or you'd like to gain some
Advantage from that presentation you'd
like to say something about those
functions that represent those vectors
so what what can you say about the fs in
your closed linear span of the
orthonormal family F that you started
with well beyond Square integrability it
it of course depends on the choice of
the orthonormal family that you
take so if f is complete if f is the
basis for L2 then you can say nothing I
mean that they're square integrable and
that's the end of the
story but if f is thin and in some sense
that is opposite to
completeness then in fact we we expect
some properties we expect improved
integrability so let's let's do that
let's let's see what happens and and the
setting that we choose here is the
harmonic analysis on the discrete Cube
so we look at we look at all minus one
one valued functions on a all Boolean
functions on a we call it Omega I
subscript it by Omega sub a again
because a will change from Context to
context but as I speak I'll I'll just
say Omega I won't say Omega sub a so we
have omega it's a compact AB billian
group har measure the uniform measure is
p and now we take the raker system on
this Omega these are simply the
coordinate functions they're independent
right you take an Omega in your big
Omega and R sub Alpha of Omega is simply
the alpha coordinate of Omega so they're
these are the coordinate functions
they're
independent you now consider the walshes
the Walsh characters these are all
finite products of distinct
rakers and the basic fact in this
context is that the walshes comprise the
character group of
Omega specifically the walshes form a
basis for big
L2 L2 of Omega on one hand on the other
hand the rakers form a basis for the
walshes right basis in the sense that
they generate the Walsh
characters so R is thin so what does
that mean how does that reflect in the
harmonic analysis that we do well we
take the canonical unitary equivalence
between our ukian space and the span of
the
rakers okay so we'll call it U so X goes
to ux and then we have one of the big
theorems of analysisin inequalities and
that says
that the tail estimates of U X are
subgaussian okay so that tells you
something about that tells you how how
big functions are in the closed linear
span of the rakers in the L2 closed
linear
span okay so this is henin's kin's
theorem there's an interesting history
connected with this
theorem uh we won't go into it
but it's and again it's you one cannot
overstate the importance of this of this
fact it's really it's the foundation of
many many things that are done here
actually well the point is that at this
point we we we we know that the sub
gaussianity the the the the the exponent
two is optimal it cannot be replaced by
a larger exponent okay subgaussian
estimates are the best you can hope for
so well question can we do better with
with other representations of the ukian
space okay now clearly
well we cannot do better if we want to
pres if we want to stick to unitary Maps
so we have to surrender something we
have to well we have unitary maps and we
have to surrender some properties
that will give us a chance of
improving the properties of functions in
the image of that map U that will be
called it another name
now well what you'd like to do is I mean
first let's see what we would like to do
with our representation so first of all
we'd like to keep control over the size
of the vectors that we are representing
that's one thing we you know the length
of the vector should be registered
somehow by its
representative and also you'd like to
record you'd like to register the angle
between two vectors so the dotproduct of
X and Y should be somehow recorded by
the representatives of X and Y so for
example in fact that's not just an
example that's exactly the question that
we're focused on at this point can we
find the probability space Omega Omega
mu and continuous
injections from the ukian space little
L2 into big L2 so that the image of X
under Fe in the L Infinity Norm which is
really the best you can hope for in
terms of size is going to be uniformly
bounded if x ranges over the unit ball
and the dot product is in fact
registered by the soall in a product I
say so-called because you notice that I
don't have the bar there it's not the
the the on the left side you have the
dot product X of alpha y of alpha summed
over a but on the right side you don't
have Fe of X Fe of
Y Bar okay so there is a and we'll come
to that point towards the end of the
talk but this is the this is our
challenge now can we find can we find a
an injection that does these two things
okay well this is exactly where Groen di
comes in okay so at first
glance what's going on so first of all
Groen dig
inequality the statement well it's a
striking it's really a striking
inequality it says that there is a there
is a universal constant K so that for
every finite array of
scalers the supremum of what you see on
the right that involves scalers in minus
one one dominates up to a constant there
is a price you have to pay up to a
constant a universal constant the same
kind of supremum but this time the
products of scalers on the right are
replaced by dot products of vectors in
your ukan space so this is quite a quite
a
statement it's
um it's hard to say what motivated grend
dick to this inequal to to to this
assertion uh one can speculate we won't
do it
here um I'd like to note however that a
special case of of this
inequality had already been proved by
littlewood about well 23 years prior so
if you take the
xjs if you take the xjs and the
inequality to be the basic unit vectors
then in fact you get what we call the
littlewood mixed Norm inequality so if
you write it down you'll see what you
get and we'll come to that inequality a
little later on in the
talk the the statement as we see it here
on the slide is not the way we had been
handed that by Groen dick he he framed
it in a in a language using topological
tensor products the paper at the time
long paper
uh etc etc uh was was not was ignored it
was ignored for 15 years or so until it
was uncovered essentially deconstruct Ed
by L and Pinsky who
essentially reproved it and and there
was some they actually did some work
there and I I I actually think that this
inequality should be called the Groen
dick lindra and Pinsky inequality but
it's not it's called the
inequality it's um its impact cannot be
cannot be understated it's been applied
in diverse areas including theoretical
computer science cannot be overstated
I'm sorry it cannot be
overstated uh what did I say cannot be
understand maybe that's true
too no
but no but of course you're right I I
mean I I made some good living out of
this inequality
so don't TI the hand
exactly so uh just a small comment it's
not a small comment but uh the
evaluation of the smallest constant that
works in this inequality which is called
the groy constant is a is an object of
pursuit it's an open question to this
day um the latest on it is uh in a paper
by four authors brevan then there are
two
marichev brothers or cousins brother
brothers I thought they were cousin
marichev and marichev and aaf no and uh
it's it's actually quite a it's it's a
beautiful piece of work it um it
improved on a previous estimate due to
crine dating to I think
77 um and they used some novel methods
actually we'll come to the constant a
little later on towards the
end but what does that have to do with
our with our story remember we are
looking for an injection that represents
Etc Etc here we have an
inequality well there's a dual statement
and the Dual statement says the
following so take now the bullan
functions on the unit unit sphere unit
ball in your ukian space so that's a
this Omega now is huge right I mean
you're looking at all minus one one
functions on on the ball and take the
rakers indexed by the ball okay so so
basically what you're looking at is the
the system of functions the system of
characters simply are independent
functions associated with each Vector in
the ball that flash plus or minus one
right and the proposition states that
the grenic inequality that statement
that we had on the previous
slide it holds precisely if and only if
there is a complex
measure Lambda on the product of Omega
with its itself a huge space so that for
all vectors in the ball X and Y the
dotproduct of X and Y is the transform
of this Lambda okay the the constant
itself kg the the grty constant turns
out to be and this is not a surprise
it's the minimum of the total variations
of the lambdas where the minimum is
taken over all possible representations
of the dot product so this proposition
is not difficult to prove it's actually
quite a
it's a form well not a formal exercise
but it's a soft exercise what what we
call in the business soft analysis in
One Direction if you know the
representation then you know the
inequality and that's an averaging
argument that's uh that's an exercise
it's an easy exercise and actually
that's yes that's an
exercise the opposite direction if you
know the in equality how do you get the
measure well that's essentially a
duality argument you use Han banak and
you use the Reese representation
the Reese's name will come up again in
the talk uh this Reese that I just
mentioned is uh F Reese how do you
pronounce his name in Hungarian the
first name FES fredes is fer fres
fres uh so this is the one brother the
older brother and then we'll we'll meet
the younger brother later on anyway this
is uh F ree question so where is the
Matrix here
where do we see ah well okay so that's
we have to do some work but let's keep
that for the question after the talk
right I mean that it's a good question
how do you right so it's so there is
some you have to kind of look at it in
the right way and and you apply Rees
Hanan F re Han banak and you get
it well we're still not quite there
we're still not quite there we still
need our injection so corer and now we
come to a part of our life formula the
the Corral is that the growth and deck
inequality holds precisely if and only
if there is a probability measure on
this very large space Omega and a
function a one one map Fe from your
ukian space into L2 so that the L
Infinity Norm of f of x is uniformly
bounded by the by
the by the length of the vector X and
the inner product is
preserved okay so this is the point
where I want to point out
that this fee well there are two things
that you you want to point out well it's
more than two things three
things the this Fe does not commute with
complex conjugation in other words it's
not true that the integral of f of x f
of Y Bar is the same as the integral of
f of x f of Y Bar okay so it's and
that's a an important
Point well before I move on to the next
slide and indicate the next issue
uh let me just say the proof is
essentially routine you take the
previous proposition that I had and you
polarize the mappings that you had in
the proposition so this may sound a bit
mysterious but if you sit down and try
to get the corollary from the
proposition you you'll get it and this G
is exactly the same Conant exact well no
the the good point the the K now now the
constant is K squ
it's not the same constant but uh if you
say if if the K here is the best K that
works for whatever map you have then the
square of it is exactly the growth and
constant excuse
me so there's still a question all right
so we still have a question first of all
so the first obvious question is that
the assertion that we had the corollary
that we had on the previous Slide the
underlying measurable space
Omega is very large the probability
measure mu is non- constructible you
have absolutely no idea what it looks
like in fact this is the one that's
obtained by the re representation
theorem and the Han banana simply tells
you that it exists and that's
it and the injection fee is highly it's
in fact nowhere continuous remember you
had rademakers right r subx r suby you
had the transform of your Lambda and
so the points in the unit wall flash
plus or minus one independently there's
no there's no continuity here so it's
highly
discontinuous so the obvious question is
can you find a more tractable standard
whatever that means probability space
along with A constructible continuous
injection that does exactly the same
thing okay so this is your this is your
task okay so now well so let's see if we
can if we can do this so now let's go
back back a bit in history okay so this
is Groen 1953 or 1968 really and
pinski so now we come to the L1 L2 kin
inequality and that's the little wood
inequality that I had that I have
mentioned a little while ago so the
kenin inequality the L1 L2 kenchin
inequality states that on the span of
the rakers the L1 and the L2 Norms are
equivalent there is a
constant Kappa so that Kappa s the L1
Norm of a linear combination of rakers
dominates the L2 Norm this is what we
know to be hypercontractivity right the
the reverse inequality is obvious but
this is the this is the news the
inequality was um the way it stated uh
was proved first as far as I can tell by
littlewood in 1930 and it was
independently observed by orlet Stein
housee Zigman about the same time time
about the same time but as far as I can
tell again littlewood was the first so I
put littlewood's name
there the the constant that littlewood
came up with actually I think six is
wrong I I worked out the proof last
night and I came up with six the
littlewood's proof but I think that
three he he I think that his constant is
root three in any event the the what the
constant is and it will become an issue
in in a in a little while was an open
question that uh was out there for a few
decades and it was a question that
attracted
attention uh it was solved in 1976 in a
master's thesis by by
jar and in fact well as you can see on
the slide the constant equals run2 which
is interesting because root2 is exactly
the constant that you get when you take
a two point set a so the two points give
you the
constant so here you have here you have
henin's
inequality so let's so what we have to
remember from this slide is that it's
equivalent the the inequality is
equivalent to the assertion that the
Span in L1 is the same as the Span in L2
of the
rakers okay now if you take the Dual
assertion so what does that mean that
means that L2 subr star is L1 so the
Dual spaces are the same and what it
what it says is
that so this is the
the assertion that we begin from that
every the the Dual statement says
exactly the following that every Vector
in the ukian space every X in little L2
of a can be interpolated by a transform
of a bounded measurable function on the
rakas so for every
X there is an there is a function G in L
Infinity so the transform of G
restricted to the rers equals x okay so
it you have this nice interpolation so
in another way stating
this is that there is a mapping G which
is equal to U this is your unitary map
plus little G that's we'll call that the
perturbation so that g of X in the L
Infinity Norm is bounded by the squ < TK
of 2times the times the length of the
vector X okay so this is exactly this is
actly kin's inequality with the best
constant < tk2 so we refer to G as the
interpolant for obvious reasons and we
refer to little G as the orthogonal
perturbation associated with it also for
the obvious
reasons okay so it looks like well it
looks like we're almost there in
achieving our
injection but kinin falls short why is
that well we have a we have an
interpolant G with which does what it
should do equation 19 tells us that g of
X hat at the rers is equal to the vector
X at
Alpha at the rer point it does not
guarantee its continuity we don't know
that g is continuous it's simply given
to us by an application of the axum of
choice
hanak and it also doesn't guarantee that
the dot product is
preserved right because Parts ofal tells
us that the dotproduct of X and Y
is the integral of G of X with G of Y
Bar minus the integral of G ofx little G
of X little G of Y Bar and we have
absolutely no assurance that the second
term in 21
vanishes right so we don't have our
representation that we we're looking
for but but there is an idea we have an
idea here and what's the idea well let's
look at par again and what paral tells
you is that when you integrate G of X
against G of Y Bar you get the
dotproduct of X with Y plus an error
term which
is the dotproduct
of two
vectors whose coordinates are indexed by
the compl of the rakers in the walshes
this is paral right the integral the
integral that you see what I call the
error is exactly the dot bip bip it's
exactly the dot product of two
vectors whose coordinates are indexed by
the by the complement of the roders in
the Walsh Walsh
system well so here's the idea take the
take those two
vectors apply the interpolant G to each
of them apply par of all's formula again
in the form of
22 subtract the result from the original
22 and
repeat okay so this is so this is the
idea it's a simple idea
right so basically what you do is you
recognize the air and you'd like to wipe
it out how do you wipe it out you feed
it back to the interpolant and do it
again but okay so an iteration how would
let let's be a bit more precise well the
the the the precise for formalism would
be this let's assume not that a is
infinite your indexing set is infinite
well if there if a is infinite then a
and the complement of the wall of the
rakers in the wall system have the same
cardinality and you can have a b you can
you can have a matching you have a bje
between a and the and
the complement of the rakas and the
walshes W take away
R so you now start with x in your ukian
space and you iterate ly Define vectors
in your ukian space as follows you
initialize X of one is going to be X and
then X of J is going to be the
perturbation the the transform of the
perturbation at the point sent by the
bje to the
rers okay so this is your X of J and
now you write down 26 and you're
practically finished right you if you
followed what was going on right
you step one there's an error you
correct the err you correct it again and
again and again and you have an
alternating sum of course there is a
problem right and the problem is
Convergence how do we know that the
iteration
converges there's another problem a
technical issue but we'll come to that
let's focus right now on the the
convergence okay are we making
sense consistency the other issue I'm
sorry speak up consist consistency could
be another issue if I do in different
ways do I get the same right there is
another issue there is another issue but
the other issue is
a is minor compared to this issue the
convergence is the is the first thing
that you want to
resolve
well how do you guarantee the
convergence well the convergence you you
would you would get a an iteration say
via a geometric series argument if you
could guarantee that the L2 Norm of the
perturbation is uniformly below one why
is that because then well you see why
right you you make the air you feed it
to your interpolant you knock it down
you make the airor again you feed it to
the interpolant you knock it down so you
have a geometric
sequence and you're in business you're
you're you're done okay but so you'd
like the inter you'd like the
perturbation to be in Norm less
than uh eke keeper how much time do I
have oh well
okay so you'd like the Interpol the
perturbation associated with the
interpolant to be less than strictly
less than one uniformly but in fact the
hin constant root2 gives you no better
than one and that's the best you can
do so question can you find an
interpolant G with an orthogonal
perturbation that is
uniformly less than one for all
X for all X in the ball so we call such
an interpolant g a uniformizing
uniformizing interpolant We have we
still have to be more precise so let's
move on to the next stage so you know
uniformizing constant so what we do
precisely is this you take a Delta and
you take an X in your unit ball and you
look at U sub a x Delta and that's the
inum of the interpolant that matches X
in such a way that the perturbation in
the L2 Norm is less than or equal to
Delta Delta is now less than one now you
know that the first line this line
is finite there's no issue there's no
problem there because hin inequality
tells you that you can do
this
however what you want to do is you want
to take the soup over all X in the unit
ball and here here lies the problem how
do you know that that's finite so then
the next step is you want to soup over
all a in case your a happens to be
finite and we refer to U of Delta the as
Delta goes from 0 to one as the
uniformizing constants which are
associated with the rakra
system and the issue at hand is compute
U of Delta so notice at this point that
U of 1 is equal to < tk2 that's we made
that comment before that's immediate
from the fact that the hinin constant is
< tk2 but it's not obvious a prior
obvious that U of Delta is finite for
Delta less than
one so there is some work we have to
do well so now we come well so another
issue right that's that's another issue
and the other issue is continuity so
let's just State this the uh the Dual
formulation of thein
inequality gave us an interpolant but it
said nothing else about that interpolant
it was simply Chosen and we don't know
that it's chosen continuously so can you
can you find an interpolant G which will
be continuous on its domain continuous
with either with respect to either the
norm topologies or the weak topologies
both are actually relevant for our
purposes well the uh the good news is
that answers to both questions
uniformize ability and continuity are
affirmative and both are obtained by the
use of what we call Reese
products so this Reese is the younger
brother of f Reese this is Marcel
ree I think that F re
spent his time in Budapest but uh Marcel
ree spent his time in Sweden they didn't
work in the same place just
a historical
curiosity the Reese product well we saw
the Reese products in previous lectures
I think Kristoff had them on the on the
board today so forly a Reese product is
simply a product
of R this is the function one plus X of
alpha R Alpha where X is any scal of
valued function whatsoever on a okay at
the outset you make no assumptions about
X and you define the re
product formally to be the Walsh series
that we have in equation 30 you notice
that that's exactly what you would want
the product to be so that's our object
and the basic question is what does this
Walsh series represent
well this uh it's a very very useful
device its importance cannot
be
overstated uh it provided it in the 60s
and 70s in the French School of
mathematics harmonic analysis it uh was
a focal
point um a very useful device extremely
useful device and a very natural
device so our interest is is in what we
call L Infinity valued re products so
now what we do is so first of all let's
define q of x to be the imaginary part
of the Rees product at the imaginary I
time x so basically what you're doing is
you're looking at the Walsh series that
I have in the middle of the slide you're
picking up only the Walsh characters of
odd order and you alternate them
okay and the key Lemma and this is
really the the Crux
of the matter the key Lemma is that if
your X is a
vector a real valued Vector in ukian
space then q q of X is the wall series
of an element in L Infinity it
represents a bounded measurable function
whose L Infinity Norm is bounded by e to
the length of the vector squared divided
by two okay we'll we'll get to that it's
not difficult to see
so this is one one part the LMA
continues then you then you have then
you have the assertion that Q Suba is an
interpolant well better than that it's
homogeneous on the rers that is to say
that when you look at u q Suba of x
divided by U and you look at the
transform at the rers you pick up
exactly X so the object on the left side
of the equality in 32 is an
interpolant moreover and this is the
uniformize ability or what will give us
the uniformize ability when you look at
the
transform
of this interpolant restricted to the
complement of the rakers you have this
estimate U times root hyperbolic sign
and so on and so
on and
finally still the key
Lemma the function Q is ellip shit's
function in particular it's continuous
okay
so this is dilemma let's sketch the
proof the proof is not hard it's it's
actually very
Elementary so to check that Q sub a is
in L
Infinity you take any finite set in the
spectrum of q q of X the Spectrum has to
be countable clearly because X is a
vector in ukian space case accountably
supported and then you for that finite
set F you estimate the product the the
re
product and you estimate it it's an
elementary estimate you estimate the L
Infinity Norm as the product of 1 + x of
alpha s to the sare root you just pass
the modulus inside and then you have the
second line that's a straight equality
and then you state the
inequality and out finally now that you
have your estimate for finite products
you take a sequence of finite sets that
increase to the
Spectrum and you check that the
corresponding re products converge in a
weak star sense to Q Suba with a norm
bound that you have in 35 so that that
takes care of the first part of the
Lemma
the the inter so you notice now that for
every U
the re product U QA of x divided by U
can be expanded in a way that I have in
36 that's just arithmetic and by looking
at it you see immediately that it's it's
an interpolant because on the rers it
picks out exactly X and then the next
step is to estimate the L2 Norm of the
perturbation which is the second
term and that's a that's an estimate
that's an elementary estimate
you go through
it to check that the function is
lipshits is also estimates you have to
do the
arithmetic and so that's the key
Lemma
well we have a corollary so now I think
we're done I mean the hard part is
behind us the uniformizing constants of
the radak system are Big O of one over
root Delta that comes out of the
corollary that we had the the dma that
we had and in particular Q Suba is a
uniformizing interpolant with Delta and
the constant here is hyperbolic sign
minus one square root which is uni Which
is less than
one so so we're essentially finished so
now we can go back to Gro and Dick and
there are a few technical issues that we
have
to
finished okay we're finished with
showing that we can make the iteration
that we fantasized about work we have
our
perturbation is below one this gives us
well we'll we'll see what it gives us
yeah so but well be about eight slides
ago I I showed you this fantasy that we
had about the iteration fantas but and
the fantasy was hinged yeah right so let
me just you know so the the fantasy was
hinged to being able to show that the
perturbation can be Bel one okay so we
can so there we have it below one so now
let's see how our whether we can make
our fantasy of
reality well so now we have to get now
we have to get a little technical um eke
keeper 10 minutes okay so I can tell you
some more
stories so we have to get a little
technical now so we take our our set a
our indexing set a and we break it down
to a countable number of pieces Each of
which has the the same cardinality as a
okay you can do that and then you set up
your BS okay so one bje t sub one is
going to take you from A1 to a and then
T J will take you from AJ into the
complement of the rak's indexed by a
subj minus one in the
walshes
okay actually there's a eror this should
be a subj this is actually an important
point because we'll need some
Independence anyway so this is a sub so
the bje takes you from AJ into on to
it's a one one on to map from AJ to W so
walshes a subj index by a subj remove
the rakers sorry A subj minus one remove
the
rers index by a subj minus one okay so
we have these BS and now we do exactly
what we well fantasized about okay so we
now take our specific interpolant which
is the Q that we we were given by the
Lemma and uh we run with it right so X
we initialize X sub1 is going to be X
composition with t one that simply takes
my Vector X from a into
A1 and now X of J is going to be the
vector which is the transform of the
perturbation in the previous step
at the complement of the rm's index by a
subj minus
one
and an iteration of par Val's formula
gives us the formula that we have in the
center of the slide I should have
numbered it but I didn't have space for
it but anyway so here it is so the inner
product of X with Y is given by this
alternating sum this time we have minus
Delta s to the J minus one that's the
good news now we have we are guaranteed
that the iteration converges because
Delta is less than one and we have these
integrals but remember we still want our
we still need an injection well remember
the ajs are so this is easy now I mean
the hard work is behind us the ajs are
disjointed so the Q ajs are independent
because they sit on Independent pieces
of the rers so you can switch the
integral and the summation with impunity
so the inner product of XY is given by
equation 39 well you're not quite there
because um One Piece has minus Delta to
the J minus one the other piece has
Delta to the J minus one but this is
this is not serious because now you can
Define f sub a of x to be simply the
imaginary I Delta to the J minus one Q
of x to the J Delta divided by Delta J
minus one and you're finished you're
essentially finished so your theorem now
states that you have a
map F sub a taking you from the unit
ball of the ukan space into Big L
Infinity which is a uniformly bounded
injection which is both Norm continuous
and weakly
continuous with the properties that you
were looking for that the L Infinity
Norm of fa of X is bounded by a constant
K uniformly in the unit ball
and the inner product is registered by
the integral that we have f of x time F
of Y with respect to the uniform measure
on
Omega so that's our so that's the main
theorem so that's the
theorem well uh there's a word of
caution and that I referred to that
before
sure we have lots of the time we can
even tell you stories about par ofal yes
does this you didn't use grth andic
inequality to prove I didn't use what
I'm sorry you didn't use grth and
inequality no this is this proves this
is a proof of grth and inequality you
can yeah so this implies remember the
grth and inequality is equivalent to a
yeah so so now if if you follow the the
argument then you not you not know how
to prove growth and Di inequality so
this is now as far as the historical
point this is now our time this you see
like okay no yeah thank you
yeah so right so this implies growth and
dig I mean a bit of propaganda I mean
there there is uh this map has some more
properties um which uh I didn't talk
about um this map multil linearizes very
neatly it goes into higher Dimensions
very nicely it has a homogeneity
property that allows you to go to higher
Dimensions but that's a story for
another time if there is another time so
a word of
caution um and this is actually an
important point an important word this
map F sub a of the theorem or any other
map with the same properties could not
possibly commute with conjugation
complex
conjugation uh this is I made that
comment before I'm making it again so
specifically when you look at the image
of the unit
ball the real unit ball that image under
fee must
contain elements with not zero imaginary
parts so that there's no way to there's
no way to to flip the conjugation and
fee that's and actually that's the
nature of the Beast I mean that there's
a good reason why you can't do that
there is a there is a very it's a
significant result by kashin and jar
this is the same jar who gave us thein
constant and it states that if for every
integer n you can find vectors
in the unit ball of ukian space so that
if you have bounded
functions which represent the dot
product of VJ VK in the way that you
would like them to represent to be
represented by the functions then the L
Infinity Norm must be bigger than K *
the log of n log n^ the 1/4 and that
actually turned out to be a a crucial
result for some work of no Alon and no
in another in
another part of this story but we won't
go into that so word of caution it does
not commute so finally let me just leave
you with a with a question constants
what about the constants
well the Groen di constant says nothing
about continuity I mean right the the
the Groen dick inequality is equivalent
to this representation and the
representation in fact the way it's
formally stated
says nothing about continuity of the
injection that does the work for you so
you really have another constant here
you have a constant which involves
continuous injections so the question is
suppose you formalize this notion this
constant we'll call it K sub GC
continuous growth and dig and you write
down whatever you need to write down and
then you ask what about the relationship
between the Groth and D constant and the
continuous Groth and D constant
so I I'm not asking about the
computation of these two
constants well I don't know so this is a
question so KGC is the constant is the
constant that you get from insisting
that your injection be continuous says
this is fine exactly but does it give
also a number yeah yeah there are
numbers they they involve okay so the
numbers the the numerical evaluations
are inherited from the uniformizing
constants that you obtain from your Rees
products and you can do better because
you can you can the same argument using
Rees products can be you can you can use
some gaussian you can use gaussian
variables you can get
slightly oh yeah no it's a Well I don't
know e to the e s divided by it involves
it involves uh the natural natural
e
um what what is interesting about the
constant is well okay I
mean um there is a non-c communative
version of this inequality and actually
this method can be adapted again this is
a story for another time can be adapted
to to give that non-commutative version
and in the non-commutative version the
constants that Hagar up and P and get
are very similar to the constants that
you get here from the from this approach
so there's something going on here with
the I I mean I believe that there's a
strict inequality I mean there's a
question here whether the two are the
same it's possible that they are the
same I would be surprised but you know
that doesn't mean
anything and
so I thank
you more
questions yes sir
yeah my question is n I think you were
hinting us to ask you about the history
of paral oh well no not really well
paral is an interesting character antoan
parali born in 1750 something died in
183 something but the significant part
about him is that he was a royalist he
was he was a royal and he actually set
in prison uh for composing poetry
against the regime I think he wrote
against Napoleon he was he was a
royalist and the interesting thing about
well and groden dick if you know Groen
dick is the exact opposite Groen dick if
you know is the anti- royalist anyway
so yeah I said they I just wanted to us
so now this dual form I
apologize um so this dual form so you
are saying that that's gives you a
richer kind of Investigation than the
Primal form well and so why is that so
is not the Dual
completely so okay so right so the Dual
form tells you so you have growth index
inequality and that's exactly equivalent
to an existence of a measure and that ex
that measure gives you this mapping fee
this injection fee but now you can ask
questions about this mapping fee so this
is something that the inequality itself
doesn't hint at you have to move out to
the Dual world to explore what else can
be true there so the the the the sorry
and you have by the way you have the
same issue with the henin inequality the
henin inequality also involves an issue
of continuity never mind the uniformize
ability see in in that in that world too
you have henin constant but the henin
constant in the Dual on the Dual side
does not say anything about the
structural properties of the
interpolant could be continuous who
knows if you insist on continuity and
you prove it I mean in fact we proved it
then the constants go up in fact um the
constant that you get by insisting that
your interpolant be continuous is e to
the
1/2 rather than root2 so I mean it's a
as far as I know it's an open question
whether whether or not this is you know
whether root2 is the so-called
continuous constant I believe that it's
not and you asked about about the uh
well I guess you didn't ask all right so
was yeah no I asked about where do we
see the M the coefficients of the Matrix
in the Dual right so well so what you
don't see the The Matrix what you see is
the Matrix
becomes you you associate with a matrix
Walsh
pooms whose Spectrum lies in the Walsh's
indexed by subsets of the unit ball I
you have to do a little
mind game and that's so basically the
grenic inequality is a statement about a
certain linear functional that is
bounded so the so the inequality says
the there's a certain function which is
bounded but then you
apply um did I say FES yes FES you apply
rees's theorem and you get your measure
and then to get the injection you have
to polarize and and you're done with
that so that's
yeah so you have you know if the the qu
power in the log is sharp no actually
alone and and prove that you get one
it's log n log n or maybe log n to the
one2 I can't one I'm sorry one no log in
to the 1 half I think maybe yeah to the
one2 yeah they improved it and actually
yeah and that was that was a critical
Improvement half canot be improved
half cannot be
improved
okay more questions
discusss thank you very
much